[Music]
in just a few days the era of daniel
craig and his legacy is james bond will
come to an end initially scoring the now
53 year old had to prevail against all
kinds of opposition for his first film
casino royale and he did so with
complete success he is frequently
mentioned as one of the best actress
ever in a row with double 07 veterans
like sean connery and pierce brosnan all
the more reason to wonder what will
happen to james bond after the upcoming
no time to die given that dania crack
will literally no longer play any part
rumors about who might succeed him as
james bond have been circulating for
months names like henry cavill or tom
hardy are brought up though without any
concrete clues lead actor daniel craig
also expressed his opinion on the matter
as he revealed in an interview with
radio times in his view the character
should not be portrayed by a woman in
any case since new role could be just as
easily be invented producer barbara
broccoli has a similar opinion having
said a few years ago that bond is
definitely a male figure she believes
that male characters should not be
turned into women so instead with
lesiana lynch in the upcoming film there
will be female 07 who is a character of
her own unrelated to james bond but for
now the fifth and last film with daniel
craig no time to die will have its
american theatrical release on october
8th 2021
although the release of the flash is
still more than a year away we are
already being regularly supplied with
news on the dc adventure this was the
case last monday as well when 48 year
old director andy muschietti posted a
picture of a red batman suit without
further comment in the middle can be
seen a yellow lightning bolt on the
familiar bat symbol the combination of
the two elements naturally erases some
questions some believe it harold's red
death others think that the image refers
to a plot from the comics where barry
loses his actual suit and is temporarily
given one by batman there have been at
least a few hints about the latter
theory from muskiette in the past the
only clear thing is that barry travels
to the past according to the comic
narrative flashpoint and consequently
changes the present significantly among
other things it might be possible that
we will see ben affleck's and michael
keaton's version of batman in the
leading role we will definitely see as
ramila as the eponymous superhero the
flash will be released in cinemas on
november 4th 2022
last week the annual batman day took
place on the 3rd in september as usual
fitting lead director matt reeves and
composer michael giaccino spoke out via
interesting posts oscar winner giachino
tweeted the video of his orchestra
performing the dramatic and atmospheric
background music of the blockbuster
moreover he also hinted at the dc fandom
on october 16th which should be a good
sign for musically inclined batman fans
after all it is to be expected that you
will then get to hear more than a mere
30 seconds director matt reeves did not
miss the opportunity to contribute
something to batman day either taking
the fans to his editing room there you
can see a scene from the movie on the
screen which we unfortunately can't
quite make sense of yet reefs also
refers to being able to show more of the
production in a few weeks which makes
fans around the globe very perceptive
man is of course the trailer which will
premiere at fandom and offer longer
insights into the dc adventure for the
first time hopefully including the
penguin the riddler and all the other
villains anyway we are very excited are
first looking forward to the dc fandom
on october 16th but of course especially
to the theatrical release of the batman
on march 4th 2022
in time for the second anniversary of
disney's in-house streaming service the
parent company is holding a global
disney plus day subscribers can hope for
all kinds of new content whether it be
from pixar marvel star wars national
geographic or even the simpsons this
should then be especially interesting
for those who are not currently
subscribed to the streaming service
however anybody who calls a disney plus
subscription their own can look forward
to all kinds of exclusive offers and
promotions since on the occasion of the
giant corporation's second birthday the
blue carpet will be rolled out for all
subscribers as it says in an official
press release bob chapack the ceo of
disney even speaks of an annual tenpo
event that affects all areas of the
company be the disney theme parks or the
movie and series offerings fans of the
mcu should get their money's worth with
the streaming premiere of shanghi and
the legend of the ten rings you can also
look forward to jungle cruise the
christmas reinterpretation home sweet
home alone the frozen spin of olaf
presents and many other premieres the
event is scheduled to take place around
the globe on november 12 2021 and will
surely include some more surprises we
are definitely excited about all the new
content
the production of fantastic beasts 3 was
anything but a piece of cake first there
was the big outcry about johnny depp in
his role as grindelwald and then there
was the pandemic finally for the first
time in a while there's some news about
the third installment of the popular
movie series revolving around newt
scamander and many fans will be
delighted for two reasons first the
official title of the previously
nameless blockbuster has now been
revealed fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore is now the name of the
upcoming spin-off after the events of
the part 2 this is honestly not a big
surprise so if you haven't seen the
second part yet you should urgently do
so the second piece of news concerns the
release date of the fantasy adventure
you won't have to wait until july 2022
after all because luckily the film has
been moved up by just about three months
soon enough you will be able to see
eddie redmayne as nudes commander
asramila as credence barebone jude laws
albus dumbledore and max mikkelsen as
the new gelat grindelwald fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore will be
released on april 15 2022 in the united
states
the three park franchise of the popular
pitch perfect movies has already got
many ladies nights going after it has
been known for over a year that the
fourth part of this series is to be
released news regions earlier this week
that is serious is also being planned
according to the report from variety 37
year old adam devine is set to star in
his role as bumper allen devine who made
his last appearance in 2015's pitch
perfect 2 will hopefully not be the only
returnee from the film series fans are
of course also in hopes that anna
kendrick is becca rebel wilson as fed
amy brittany's known as chloe and anna
camp as aubry will also make a comeback
however there is still no reliable
source of information on this on the
other hand it is known who will be in
charge of the project namely producer
and pitch perfect veteran elizabeth
banks the plot is to take place after
the events of the movies and will
thematize the music career of bumper who
moves to germany in the hopes of
becoming a music star there the story
was conceived by screenwriter megan
amaran and official title of the series
has not yet been announced when exactly
this series will be released is
unfortunately also still uncertain but
we will of course keep you up to date as
always
well that's it with our latest news in
case you're into spooky things and
looking for anything else to watch we
can definitely recommend the new trailer
for halloween kills which you can find
on our channel we've recently also
uploaded the video showcasing upcoming
blockbuster movies in the first half of
2022 so be sure to check that one out
see you next time
[Music]